um
tomorrow my neighbor has to hurry I'm
I'm here Shanna I'm outside oh they're
gonna call you
oh yeah all right
thank you
um
foreign
ERS on your on the Instagram
that is managing for you do you have
orders
uh have Grandma help you get into what
are your jeans mom
um
in the morning
uh
it was on the box
yeah they'll let her take what she has
and then they'll order more if they have
to yeah
and then
we'll just need to see like the ballot
it's gonna be the white vehicle back
there
I'll go to that I love you honey
passenger side yeah
is that property
all right though
we're gonna do we're gonna bring you
inside real quick get you out of the one
car right
step out for me yeah
[Music]
we're gonna go through these doors over
here
and then there's going to be a hallway
to your left there have you take a left
there for me
and we'll go down to this last door here
on the left
have you stand there for me
and I'll have you take a seat over here
and what I'll do actually if you want to
face the wall for me
[Music]
so what I'll do is I don't want to keep
you in these cups for a long time I know
that kind of hurt so what I'll do is
I'll take one hand out and I'm just
going to attach it to the railing right
there all right
[Music]
do you want to take the hand please stop
your head for me
if you want to step to your left or turn
the other way I'll have you take a seat
turn the other way for me all right and
then if you want to take a seat for me
okay
[Music]
I'm just gonna squeegee a little bit all
right there you go
and then the other officers will be in
here shortly right
thank you
which one's tight the right one more and
the right one's more tight okay
I'll listen in a little bit
sorry and those cops putting any strain
on your shoulders or anything
um all right
well I'll get you down the jail
um as soon as possible and then we'll
get you out of these cups
um probably about 10-15 minutes 10
minutes
no no we'll get it for you that's all
right
um do you want any more water before we
go
[Music]
not a little bit left
[Applause]
good
and then we'll just go back out to the
same car we came in this one on here on
the left
and then what I have to do is I'll just
have you face the numbers right here
um just because you're in that room I am
just going to pat you down
um just make sure nothing else ended up
in your pockets
foreign
I still do have your medications with me
okay um so those will be checked into
the jail
I want to have C for me
um I do have a question for you it's not
um regards to the charges at all those
uh the medication that's in that little
or divider yeah what's in those I can
tell you
just the reason I asked is because the
jail might not take that divider that's
fine I don't have enough in the bottles
I think there was only a day left is
what my mom said okay and if you have
them in the bottles then that's good
um I just saw that in there and the jail
is pretty picky on prescriptions I
figured the diviner my mom can come and
get
um
yeah okay
um and then I am just going to read you
just since I have you I have you in my
custody
um I don't know what the detectives
asked you I'm just going to read you
something
um
so you have the right to counsel at this
time if you're unable to pay for Council
you'll be entitled to have one provided
without charge do you understand that
it's okay
um
and that's it so all the
uh I'm gonna put your seat belt on I'll
get you down there it's hot so hot my
vehicle can't keep up that's it harder
for you guys wearing all the stuff you
guys have to do
um and I'll get you down there so you're
out of cops I know those are
uncomfortable so just sit tie for me all
right
I think they're the detectives uh
Jacksonville oh okay but
um
yeah I got the two